ja es geht um noch mehr geld
100 milliarden euro wollen wir ausgeben
unter anderem hat der bundeskanzler herr
lindner zugerufen das soll jetzt
ausgegeben werden 100 milliarden wofür
das ist die frage auf der einen seite
hat große begeisterungsstürme gegeben
bei der industrie und bei der einen oder
anderen partei in deutschland
das zielt auf einmal ganz schnell ganz
viel geld freigegeben wird in
wirklichkeit ist es so das ist eine
kleine schatztruhe aus der wir eben
nicht jeden tag unser essen bezahlen
können und das was die streitkräfte
jeden tag brauchen der munition sondern
es ist genau für die anschaffung gedacht
die in den letzten 30 jahren nicht
tätigen konnten weil wir kein geld auf
der hohen kante hatten das heißt von
diesen 100 milliarden müssen wir die
ganz großen dinge kaufen das heißt neue
panzer neue flugzeuge alles das was wir
eigentlich seit 20 jahren versprochen
haben zu haben auf dass sich unsere
europäischen partner verlassen haben und
wir hatten wenn dieses geld jetzt
innerhalb der kürzester zeit ausgegeben
wird durch die bundesregierung weil sie
eigentlich ganz gerne möchte dass sie
keine neuen schulden extra noch
aufnehmen muss dann ist das genau das
falsche wir brauchen dieses geld dazu um
die großen projekte die über zehn 15
jahre laufen am ende bezahlen zu können
es ist so als ob sie ein auto heute
bestellen und in zehn jahren bezahlen
müssen dann müssen sie das geld dazu
haben das hatten wir bislang nicht und
diese 100 milliarden bieten uns einmalig
die gelegenheit das auszudrücken ich
hoffe dass wir nicht den fehler machen
und kurzfristig darauf setzen dass die
steuern nicht nach oben gehen oder dass
die schuldenbremse die erwägung ist also
finanzpolitik sondern sicherheitspolitik
denn in der tat wir haben nur wenige
kilometer von ihrem pferd wenige tausend
kilometer von ihr entfernt einen kries
man fragt sich wie nach muss die
problematik musste die bedrohung noch an
europa ankommen bevor wir tatsächlich
militärischen sicherheitspolitisch
denken und nicht finanzpolitisch und vor
allem wenn man das noch betrachtet für
die heutige entscheidung der f-35
bestellung dann haben wir damit
natürlich auch die von den grünen immer
bestritten nukleare teilhabe fixiert
wenn man an dieser stelle dieses
flugzeug nimmt dann sind wir in der
bestellung eines produkts darin dass
diese
diese maschine natürlich auch die solche
waffen tragen kann genau das stimmt man
muss allerdings fairerweise sagen die
grünen haben wir den koalitionsvertrag
mit unterschrieben und da ist die
nukleare teilhabe eingehämmert worden dh
bestand jetzt kein zweifel mehr daran
dass dieses flugzeug besteht dass ein
flugzeug bestellt wird wir haben jetzt
auch eine politische entscheidung
obendrauf sogar der typ genannt worden
ist erstaunlich dass das jetzt auf
einmal so schnell gegangen ist gut als
nachricht an unsere partner das kann man
schon sagen das ist auch eine ausnahme
weil das geht jetzt ganz schnell also
relativ schnell in kauf wir haben aber
andere produkte wo wir ganz klar sagen
da wollen wir als auch unsere deutsche
industrie letztendlich nicht mehr dran
verdienen sondern sie auch
weiterentwickeln das gilt nicht nur für
bayern so das gilt auch für andere
länder in denen wir es von interesse ist
von daher geht es darum eben das geld
strategisch auszugeben und nicht zu
sagen raus mit der kohle
damit die deutsche industrie viel geld
damit verdient sondern wir als
steuerzahler und wir als land haben
interesse daran dass wir in den nächsten
20 jahren nicht noch mal auf
amerikanische produkte um nicht
zurückgreifen müssen sondern dass wir
tatsächlich das was er verschlafen haben
nachholen und in 20 jahren wieder auf
europäische produkte zurückgreifen kann
wenn man sie sind ein profi aber wenn
man diese diesen krieg anschaut dann
sind ja auch die bewaffneten drohnen die
in der von ukrainische armee angewendet
sind durchaus
wirksam gegen die russische armee die
spd hat sich in der letzten
bundesregierung immer
dagegen gewehrt die haben sie die arien
technologie einzusetzen die bewaffnete
drohnen und ich hoffe dass diese liste
die dann erstellt wird über die 100
milliarden invest auch einen großen
anteil europäischer technologie drin hat
besser schlatt schnell ausgeben das
gefällt mir als steuerzahlerin natürlich
auch sehr gut ich glaube das gefällt
jedem gut aber meine frage ist ganz klar
wie viel zeit bleibt uns denn als wir
haben jetzt so viele jahrzehnte es total
versaut also haben wir jetzt überhaupt
noch diese planungszeit oder müssen wir
jetzt eigentlich nicht ganz schnell
reagieren und vielleicht sogar hinnehmen
dass ein bisschen was aus dem ruder
läuft also erstmal die planung sind da
das ist die gute nachricht ja also es
gibt tatsächlich muss man sagen eine
schublade die man auf machen kann wo
drinsteht das brauchen wir alles denn
wir haben das ja vor jahren zugesagt
dass bis liefern und diese sachen müssen
wir liefern natürlich kann es dann
nochmal hier unterhalb bereicherung
geben davon aber das ist nicht so
wichtig wir wissen eigentlich was wir
brauchen wir wissen aber auch dass das
herzustellen ganz lange dauert teilweise
weil wir nämlich im grunde um sozusagen
erstmal skizzen zeichnen müssen der
sachen die wir eigentlich haben wollen
zumindest die die wir in deutschland
produzieren wollen das finde ich auch
richtig das heißt dass ich jetzt ganz
schnell heißt aber hat sich in zehn 15
jahren dann nichts modernes mehr habe
sondern ich kaufe das was jetzt schon da
ist das heißt im grunde macht ist
eigentlich der mix aus ich brauche ein
paar sachen ganz schnell die brauche ich
auch nicht in deutschland kaufen die
kann ich in den usa kaufen aber es gibt
andere sachen die stellen wir in
deutschland eigentlich gut her deswegen
würde ich sagen sollten sie in
deutschland kaufen und dann müssen wir
uns aber zehn 15 jahre gedulden das was
wir jetzt ausgeben hilft uns mit blick
auf die jetzige den risiken die wir
haben in deutschland und in europa mit
blick auf putin nichts mehr hier geht es
darum dass das was wir 30 jahre lang
wirklich nicht gut gemacht haben sie
haben es gesagt versorgt so kann man es
sagen bestimmt dass wir das nachholen
das braucht aber seine zeit denn das was
wir auch alle fälle nicht wollen oder
ich möchte es nicht und glaube die
regierungsparteien möchte es auch nicht
ist am ende legislatur da stehen ein
paar halbfertige produkte zu haben und
ein paar gute skandale zu haben in dem
viel zu viel geld für schlechte produkte
ausgegeben worden ist wenn ich dazu nur
eine randnotiz machen darf sieht der
experte sind und ich mich hauptsächlich
mit finanz und digital politik
beschäftige aber
erstens dieses sondervermögen ist ja da
um das aufzuholen was sie haben gesagt
30 jahre versäumt wurde damit soll
schnell was passieren immer auch schlau
also ähnlich wie bei der wii bei den
spritpreisen schlauen schnell schließen
sich hoffentlich nicht aus aber wir
haben ja auch gesagt wir halten das zwei
prozent ziel der nato rein das ist auch
ein aufwuchs an der militärausgaben den
wir dann ja über die nächsten jahre
konsequent leisten werden und und da
können sie sich noch mal besser aus
beschaffungswesen struktur und so weiter
sind ein riesenthema auch das wollen wir
ja angehen da bin ich auf die ersten
vorschläge gespannt ja gehört auch mit
dazu absolut ich glaube der größte
fehler den wir jetzt machen können ist
und das war bis die letzten tage noch
glaube ich das große interesse auch
ihrer partei dass wir dieses geld ebenso
schnell ausgeben damit es im grunde auf
die schulden mit angerechnet werden kann
und wie im grunde genommen nicht in die
situation kommen noch zusätzliches geld
auszugeben
das wäre aus meiner sicht das falsche
wir sollten dieses geld über zehn bis 15
jahre strecken und wirklich nur sie hat
mal den rolls royce daraus betragen und
nicht den sprit für rolls royce bitte
herr mordhorst wir sind hier glaube ich
sie sind noch ein bisschen jung aber ich
glaube aus einer generation könnte man
noch sagen auf jeden fall die die jugend
also auch viele auch aus unserer
generation oder auch noch jünger die
sagen ja immer gerne klima klima klima
und bundeswehr war immer völlig egal und
eigentlich war alles pazifisten heckler
& koch durfte er damals nicht mal an die
flutopfer im aartal spende weil das war
für kühnen in deutschland also der
pazifismus hat ja eigentlich regiert wie
schaffen wir es denn jetzt vielleicht
auch vor allem auch bei den jungen
wählerinnen und wählern und generell in
der gesellschaft auch wieder ja dass wir
das brauchen also die sinnhaftigkeit
darzustellen ich damals schon schockiert
beiklang koch aber ich muss auch jetzt
sagen das muss ich auch was ändern in
der warnung völlig richtig ist muss sich
was ändern eine mentalität also
grenzenloser pazifismus ist eben nicht
realistisch er kann menschenleben kosten
wie wir da sehr ernsthaft sehen und
deswegen müssen wir da immer das
richtige maß finden ich würde nicht
sagen dass dieses klischee über die die
jugend so stimmt also wir wollen auch
klima klima aber trotzdem hat die
erstwählerin relativer mehrheit uns
gewählt und wir machen ja auch andere
vorschläge in anderen bereichen deswegen
glaube ich dass die jugend da sehr
differenziert ist und ich habe vor allem
aus meinem umfeld aus menschen die auch
er mir in den sozialen medien folgen was
ja die sich für meine politik
interessieren sehr viel positives
feedback zu dieser verteidigungs
ausrüstung gehört und ich glaube das hat
mich auch ziemlich zuversichtlich
gestimmt dass wir da jetzt auf dem
richtigen weg gehen wenn wir vernünftig
machen also wenn wir jetzt die
politische lage uns anschauen dann muss
diese ampel erstens den verhandelten
koalitionsvertrag durch die dramatische
lage des nicht kalkulierbaren
krieges russlands gegen ukraine
eigentlich schon mal beiseite legen wir
diskutieren über aufrüstung wird
diskutieren über die verlängerung des
kohle ausstiegs in weitere jahrzehnte
und wir diskutieren über den
weiterbetrieb von
atommeilern
weil nur so können wir diese dramatische
situation überwinden
und dann schaue ich in gerade zwei
fraktionen in dieser koalition nämlich
in die grüne fraktion und die spd
fraktion und stelle fest da werde ich
mir das anschauen wie die diskussion
läuft das ist ungefähr so wie heute dass
jetzt gerade die meldungen kommen dass
die grünen dem lindner schon fdp tank
rabatt
in der gesamtschau muss man das schon
anschauen also wir haben nicht nur
global der ju politisch eine zeitenwende
eine zeitenwende wie es der
bundeskanzler gesagt hat sondern eine
unser simons eine zeitenwende in vielen
vielen themen die wir in den letzten
jahrzehnten vielleicht auch einer
globalen pazifistischen sicht dargelegt
haben und jetzt immer eines besseren
belehrt also ich wünsche
dieser vorhaben sehr viel freude in der
diskussion aber ich sage wir brauchen
die aufrüstung wir brauchen den
weiterbetrieb der atommeiler und wir
brauchen auch eine einen längeren
zeitplan für den kohleausstieg und da
werden noch viele fragen auf sie
zukommen